[Music]
all right we're gonna go to trey in ohio
hey trey how are you
i'm good how are you good how can rachel
not help
i was just i'm curious
so i'm 25 years old
right now i'm living on a friend's couch
for 300 a month
um
i make 45 000 a year
me my girlfriend just broke up i kind of
been thinking
um i discussed it with my roommate or
whatever and uh he told me i could stay
for a year and build my money
the only debt that i have is my vehicle
i did i have five thousand dollars um in
the savings i did have upwards uh i
think it was nine but i paid the car
down to three thousand dollars and then
i figured i would leave 2500
um in my savings kind of for backup
and then i saw my paychecks coming in on
my checking as well so that savings you
know wouldn't be touched and i could um
give as much money as possible toward
that car payment a month
i was just wondering the best possible
way to save
um with having that 250 a month car
payment
uh and me making roughly 2500 a month i
was just kind of trying to develop a
plan here
yeah absolutely
um okay so trey you you owe
5 000 left on your car right
i owe
3 000 3 000 i'm sorry 500
okay
um
are you on a
budget
um
right now i just am i try to do 25 of my
paycheck into my savings each week
that's what i'm trying to do uh
i have a emergency fund account with
like 300 on it um every week 50 dollars
goes into that out of my paycheck
um
and then i have 5 000 and saving okay
okay so trey i
want you to do a very very detailed
budget meaning you're going to list out
everything that you spend money on so
we're going to talk about we're going to
do some giving
possibly some savings we'll talk about
that in a second and then i want you to
list out all of your bills okay
but dollar amounts next to each of those
now this is everything from food
from your 300 of rent that you're
staying with your friend um
to insurance cell phone i don't care
everything that you pay for i want you
to list out
and the goal here is for
your income every month that's coming in
that that 2500 minus all of those
expenses equals zero so every dollar you
have
is going to a category so here's the
deal you make 45 000 tray i'd leave your
friend's house i'd go run an apartment
you can have some dignity as a man you
got this
and then you're gonna start paying off
this car because you only got thirty
five thousand dollar or three 3 500 left
on the car payment you got this you got
some savings throw all the savings at
the car leave a thousand dollars though
for an emergency fund go rent an
apartment do that budget and we're going
to sign you up for ramsay plus so stay
on the line trey and give you a part of
our free subscription of ramsay plus